what we're going to do in this video is
talk about roughly a thousand years of
Japanese history that take us from
what's known as the Classical period of
Japan through the Japanese medieval
period all the way to the early modern
period and the key defining
characteristic of the Classical period
is this is when Japan really began to
unify and have an imperial form and
began to borrow a lot of the traditions
and philosophy and even religion from
China then as we get into the medieval
period Japan gets fragmented it comes
under military rule and then as we get
into the early modern period
it gets reunited so as I mentioned China
had a huge influence on Japan even
though China never conquers Japan
because of how close they are many
things like the idea of a centralized
bureaucracy the Japanese borrow many of
these ideas from China during the
Classical period in fact the Japanese
rulers sent delegations to China in the
7th century in order to understand all
of what the Chinese do in order to run
their government to run their country
and they start to borrow a lot of the
ideas of Buddhism and Confucianism and
merge it with some of their own beliefs
which are often known as Shinto which
you can view as the original Japanese
belief system so the first part of the
Classical period that we're going to go
into some depth is the Heian period its
capital at hey Yong Kyo modern-day Kyoto
and as I mentioned it was known for
taking a lot of these ideas from China
and particularly the Tang Dynasty in
China and bringing them to Japan the
Heian period was known as a Golden Age
of Japan it was a time of culture it was
a time of architecture people in the
imperial court would focus on the arts
they would focus on philosophy as an
example this right over here is the bo
Doan
temple in Kyoto which shows the level
and this is actually part of it and it
shows the level of cultural advancement
of this time as I mentioned the arts
were big deal and women in the imperial
court of hey Yong China had a lot of
influence in fact the most influential
family the Fujiwara family maintained
its influence by having the Emperor's
marry women from their family and those
women would end up having a lot of
control over the emperor and of course
the next Emperor but to get a sense of
the arts of this period here's an
excerpt from The Tale of Genji which was
written by Lady Murasaki who was
believed to be a member of the Fujiwara
family and Lady Murasaki gets a lot of
credit before Chaucer before Shakespeare
she is by many historians viewed as the
first true novelist that we know of in
human history not just Japanese history
but I encourage you to read it it it's
actually quite riveting The Tale of
Genji
and this is just a small quote from that
story or from that novel it's about a
very handsome prince
Genji the difference between
enlightenment and confusion is of about
the same order as the difference between
the good and the bad in a romance if one
takes the generous view then nothing is
empty and useless